[Music]
i love like the little
up everyone welcome to the lobby at
gamespot we have a long episode planned
it's going to be
about 90 minutes i don't know we're
going to hang out for a while we're
starting our end of the year discussion
so uh we have a lot to talk about and
let's dive into that first i want to
talk about a couple recent games
pete we're going to talk about the last
guardian a little bit but scott i
brought you on right now because you
reviewed dead rising four yeah just to
get those out of the way before we get
to the big picture stuff yeah and dead
rising four from what you tell me a
little bit more the same a little bit
like they're kind of like mining the
series pass to make it a little better
but it sounds like you had fun with it
you gave it a seven out of ten so i
wanted to kind of pick your brain uh
right at the beginning of the show
before we get into end of the year stuff
and again people get the last guardian
but scott you reviewed dead rising four
so tell me overall what are your
thoughts like uh before we dive into the
nitty gritty yeah i mean i think your
your summary was fair uh it's it is a
fun game i really enjoyed it but it's
also kind of retreading all ground is
doing a lot of the same stuff the series
has always done um i don't know that it
necessarily does much of it better i
mean it sort of depends on the aspect of
the game you're talking about but yeah i
mean it is more dead rising do you like
hitting zombies with wacky objects do
you like kind of dark humor and open
world settings then like this is the
game for you yeah i played at a few
preview events and
again like you said it did feel very
much like dead rising three to me kind
of like uh they were just embracing the
chaos of things they're embracing the
creativity of the kills not that one and
two didn't have that but i feel like
three really you know leaned into that
crafting four kind of expounded upon
that with the like mods that's your
actual like body the exo suit right how
much did that happen because that was
what i was looking for not much actually
like so you can sort of find them around
the world and certain campaign missions
kind of force you into one um but
unfortunately you can't just like it's
not like something you can unlock and
have with you at all times it's just
something that's like occasionally as
this like brief moment you get to mess
around in an exo suit i mean it's
actually just a really really minor part
of the experience and it's fun when it
comes up like it's super super powerful
so you are essentially invincible for
the duration it's like getting a star in
mario right you just like completely run
through and destroy everything in front
of you for like 30 to 40 seconds and
that's pretty cool but you know the the
fun kind of wears off after a little
while so lay out the structure for me
i'm seeing like these almost like
graphic novel s cut scenes but i'm also
seeing you know like just this massive
open world whereas you know the first
two games were kind of on this timer i
believe the countdown timer has not
returned since three ditched it yeah
what do you think of the overall
structure of dead raising for in its
open world and whatnot yeah so there's
actually one like little bit of the
motion graphic comic thing right at the
very beginning for the most part it's
actually told through fully realized
cutscenes which is nice i feel like more
and more games are kind of shoving their
storytelling into like weird exposition
dumps over like semi-static images so i
appreciate the dead rising 4 actually
gives you full cutscenes with the the
characters interacting and uh you
actually see the story happening in real
time as opposed to having someone tell
you about what's going on later on um so
that's actually really nice i was
surprised the story was really good so
for the most part it is a a linear story
told within an open world so if you
choose to follow the campaign you are
following like you can't choose what
mission you're doing you just move on to
the next thing but at any time you can
kind of just run around this giant world
and it is i think the biggest world in a
dead rising game um so i mean yeah it's
a very traditional structure but a very
strong story for the series uh the
writing was better i would say than it
has been in previous games uh they're
like
sudden moments of seriousness that are
kind of
almost jarring in a good way uh relative
to the silliness of the action like
every now and then the game takes itself
just seriously enough that it hits you
with this like impactful emotional
moment and it kind of keeps you invested
in what's happening yeah i mean even
from the preview events i played and
thinking back to three uh
killing zombies was fun in crafting new
weapons crafting the vehicles now
crafting yourself as they were saying uh
whoa it seems like it would get
monotonous after a while did it do
enough to shake it up after a while i
mean you can craft new weapons but
you're still just plowing through these
so yeah you hit on like the biggest
thing i didn't really like about the
game which is that yeah the combat is is
very repetitive and unchanged from
previous games i mean it's very
superficial you will spend most of the
game just mashing the light attack
button as you like mow down the zombies
directly in front of you with whatever
you happen to have handy which yeah it's
totally like fun in a superficial kind
of way for a while but it does wear a
little thin and again the story is
actually pretty strong so it'll keep you
interested through the end and the combo
weapons are genuinely funny and it's fun
to kind of seek out new blueprints and
see what the world has to offer because
there are all kinds of surprises the
world is actually very deep tons of
stuff laying around tons of little
secrets to uncover and part of that is
the combo weapons so there's enough to
keep you interested uh but yeah the core
combat like the main portion of the
gameplay is a little boring and
repetitive and actually to circle back
to something you mentioned that i
totally glazed over and didn't mean to
the timer so the timer used to kind of
keep that interesting like yeah the
combat wasn't super exciting but you
were under the gun like you had a timer
ticking down so it felt really tense you
almost didn't care that the actual
combat was like mechanically kind of
routine right because you were so
focused on like oh i gotta get here and
get rescue this person and do this thing
so when you remove the timer
it does allow the open world to breathe
you can actually go explore and enjoy
everything that's out there and again
there is a lot but it does remove some
of that tension that really drove the
earliest games like the very first game
in my mind was memorable because of that
structure because it had the timer so it
loses some of its identity without that
timer but a lot of people also hated it
they hated that restriction so you know
it's a trade-off i love the timer too
like you said it kind of alleviated some
of the monotony of just killing these
zombies and like you know planning out
what you're gonna do with the time you
have i'm gonna go rescue this survivor
or like fight this mini boss or yeah
like whatever but it sounds like even
outs like when ditching the timer in uh
dead rising four it sounds like you said
it was pretty easy in general outside of
that like whether it's zombies or uh
human enemies that you're [ __ ] yeah
it's oh it's super easy like and there's
no difficulty setting to be clear it's
not like i played uneasy like nope there
is one setting that's it and uh yeah i
mean i i i don't think i ever
well i never died i definitely i never
died once in the entire game uh i
committed suicide once so i could
respawn somewhere else because i was
kind of trapped in an area that was it
was the only time so including boss
battles including fights with the like
super agile new zombies that are
introduced to this game never once even
really came close to dying uh which yeah
is a pretty sharp contrast to the very
first game in the series where you could
very easily fail you could run out of
time people would die if you didn't get
to them quickly enough like all kinds of
things could go wrong in this game it
really is more just about the fun of
smashing things up and slaughtering
zombies and you know making your way
through the story um which is fine i
mean it is fun in like kind of a popcorn
entertainment kind of way like i said in
in the review so it's it's it's good
seven is a good score right but it's not
it's not great yeah but it's it's good
but were there any like really stand out
moments that like you're gonna like
really remember about your experience
with the game or is it all just so
chaotic and silly that none of it really
stands out ah i mean
yeah
on the spot there's nothing that comes
to mind it's like oh my god you have to
play it to see this moment yeah right
but there is like just overall i really
liked the tone of the game i thought the
humor was actually pretty well executed
is this nice mix of
cheeky smart satirical humor and stuff
that's just totally goofy and silly i
really like frank his portrayal in this
game he's the returning protagonist from
the very first game uh he can be a
little grating at times because he is
like kind of a frustrating [ __ ] at
moments and he's kind of um arrogant but
that can be really funny like he makes
all kinds of commentary throughout the
campaigns all his little quips and the
sides are pretty entertaining and and
ultimately endearing so i mean there's
broad things i like about the game that
made me want to keep playing and that
made me enjoy my time overall um but
yeah nothing that's like you know it's
going to stick with me through you know
next year or the year after where i'm
just thinking back on something about it
yeah yeah reminded me like dead rising
three was one of my early xbox one games
and i remember i was kind of that was
one of the ones i returned to it was
almost cathartic despite the fact that
it's it's supposed to be based around
you know like it's not really a survival
game it's about an undead apocalypse and
everything i found it kind of ironic
that i would go to that game when i
wanted to relax and just
like
plow through zombies and everything do
you have any like i don't know do you
have any standout weapons you crafted or
vehicles that you can not to put you on
the spot i'm sure i'm seeing like the
gameplay we're looking at now shows a
few there's like a forklift that he did
something this was this is kind of an
interesting thing i thought about
talking about this more in the review
but it was a little too like into the
weeds and i just ultimately decided to
cut it but here's the thing that's
interesting to me about the combo
weapons um when it was a survival game
finding certain elements and creating
combo weapons felt super special it was
like oh my god i have this thing that's
going to keep me alive like i'm so
excited meaningful right yeah in the
first game like hunting down a mini
chainsaw which is like the best weapon
in the game felt so meaningful you were
so excited to have it while it lasted
because every every weapon was and
remains uh disposable they all break
sure but it used to be so crucial to
your survival that it was super exciting
to get something good in dead rising 4
everything's kind of disposable because
they're you're always going to find
something cool right around the next
corner guaranteed like no matter where
you are in the game you're going to find
something and make something weird yeah
you're in a suit of armor just mowing
guys down with an axe and if you're not
getting attached to that what are you
going to get attached to right i mean
it's funny it's funny and it's fun and
it's silly and that's kind of great in
its own right but yeah it kind of stops
being rewarding so to answer your
question my favorite weapon my go-to
weapon was the ice sword one because it
froze zombies which was mechanically was
very useful because they tend to mob you
because they're zombies um but also
because it was just such an easy weapon
to craft i mean you need like a can of
nitros or a can of um liquid nitrogen
which for whatever reason is in every
single place that serves food in the
game like any any restaurant anything
like that you're guaranteed to find at
least a couple of those yeah and there
are enough of them throughout the game
yeah yes exactly um that like i could
always like rely on finding a new eye
sword so that was my go-to weapon for
the entire game just because it was
powerful and super easy to craft yeah
yeah i mean like i said this seems like
a game i'm gonna return to once i finish
all the other like i don't know the last
guardian final fantasy and what and
whatnot you know not to detract from
dead rising forward it seems like a game
that's you know seems timeless i can go
back to it whenever and i'll still have
the same fun i would have on you know
when it released today it's a palette
cleanser right it's not like the it
sticks with you and changes your
perception of games you have to tell
everyone you know about it but it's like
the man like i really want to kill some
time i really want to relax or just do
something fun and mindless and you know
maybe even get some cool story along the
way like this is that game and it's it's
great for that purpose yeah awesome yeah
i'm looking forward to playing more of
that uh that is dead rising four so that
is out today december six for xbox one
and microsoft windows scott gave it a
seven out of ten you can go read his
more in-depth review on gamespot.com
seven is good remember everyone seven is
a good score also read the text the
score is stupid read the text please all
right scott thanks so much for coming on
we are gonna bump you off for someone
who's usually behind the scenes but
we'll bring her on a second but yeah
thanks so much and uh oh it's mary have
a good rest of the day all right
the next hour and twenty minutes yeah we
got a long show today yeah pete are you
gonna play dead rising at all are you
kind of caught up i want to man there's
there's so much stuff to play to prepare
for our deliberations yeah that that one
might have to wait i'm still catching up
and we just started deliberations
yesterday we can't talk too much about
those but we can kind of get so mary
kish what's up hey how's it going this
is is this your first time like in front
of the lobby camera and like how long
it's not often normally on the other
side behind the scenes yeah try casting
or running the show also important
things making me not look dumb unlike
it's a full it's a full job where were
you in the intro i didn't even know we
were live i was stretching my neck i've
messed it up now i have been there
thanks but anyway we'll do that in the
post-mortem
uh we brought you on because you
finished the last guardian correct
uh yeah we both did uh peter and i yeah
we uh i want to talk about the last
guardian because pete you reviewed it
you gave it a nine out of ten you really
love this game despite a lot of
shortcomings which you
you know like the people sitting around
in the office like it sounds like you're
frustrated most the time but then after
you know we really don't dove into what
you thought about the game and you like
can't say enough good things about it um
yeah what is it about this game that you
can't like you're glowing about uh it's
pretty simple it's trico um
just to
throw the bomb out there like i mean it
is to me the most believable character
in a video game ever be that human or
animal um and a lot of that comes down
to
the way you interact with it and
the
how that works sometimes and how it
doesn't work other times it's it's weird
to credit a game for being frustrating
and i don't want to harp on that too
much because i don't think that that is
really
a thing worth rewarding but i think the
entire like scope of trico and how you
go about your adventure with him uh
that's that's a part of it um and the
adventure as a whole is just incredible
because you
you start off with this beast that you
don't understand that you're really
impressed by and then by the end of the
game you know after all these trials
it's your best friend and you guys have
been through a lot you've changed as
charac well trico changed the most but
but i guess you the player kind of
changes you know like i
i brought a lot of myself into the
relationship uh as you guys know i tend
to fly off the handle at times
and uh and put it lightly
no comment i hate you guys
um
and trico brought that out of me you
know and when i was talking to mary
initially like her reaction was more
that she
felt that she could be patient with him
where
i maybe could only do that for a few
minutes before i just
you know i felt like there was some
serious things going on but the serious
things going on was that i was in a rush
and i wasn't actually taking the time to
get to know how he acts and how he
reacts to me which is very very
important obviously you don't want to
you can't speak for the developers do
you think any of that was intentional or
do you think this was like flaws in the
game like this frustration that you felt
i think it's a mix of both i think it's
primarily intentional i mean owed uh
spoke for himself when he said that
trico will not uh respond to you the
first time all the time okay and there
is sort of a there seems to be a
progression there
um and at some point in the game it's
sort of like hinted at that like hey
maybe you have more control over him now
than you did before
but actually replaying the game starting
from scratch i noticed that
everything i had learned about the way
he behaves uh at the start of the game
that benefits how you work with him
already
um so it's in there and i think it's
intentional
when the game has like technical blips
or maybe his tail doesn't fall the right
way and you can't get him to like move
to get it to fall where it should you
might not be able to determine the next
step in a puzzle
and because there are so many like false
paths or solutions in this game where
you think you've identified something
you don't know if it's right but you
need trico to help you figure that out
when those technical blips happen
that's definitely not intentional and
that feels kind of shitty
um
but but again i've i've never felt so
connected to a character in a video game
yeah when you were first you first
beaten it and you were like writing in
the process of writing a review you kept
talking about in the office saying like
you would start a sentence and be like
this is going to sound hyperbole or
cliche but like again like this is
seriously the most connected i've ever
been to a character this is like it i
think you use like the term like living
breathing or something similar that we
don't like to use but you said in this
case it was actually apt and yeah i know
you were you were kind of like stumbling
over yourself like no seriously i really
got attached to trico and i i want to go
back and play the game just to
experience that again for all the the
weird things that come from your
cooperation if you just focus on what
trico does and how he acts
he never really like
clip like well maybe he'll clip it like
he'll never like glitch out or like his
ai never seems confused like
it's he
it's just so convincing the fact that he
doesn't care what you want it doesn't
feel like the game is doing it by by
mistake um and it's endearing because
he's doing something very cat-like or
dog-like and
being a pet owner i think makes me a
little bit biased but i think a lot of
us even if we don't own a pet can relate
to what it means to connect with an
animal and i really felt a connection
with him in this game yeah you have to i
i've heard i unfortunately have not
played any of it yet i downloaded this
morning didn't have time but you have to
like pet him to calm him down sometimes
after he like like was defending you
from guards or attacking guards or being
attacked uh you know mary you were i
think you had in general
a more maybe you was more of a patient
person than like pete and like myself
i'm not looking forward to the
frustration that you guys have described
to me that can rear its head but you
seem to have a pretty positive
experience throughout the entire thing
if i'm not mistaken yeah i think it's
possible that it might be my
understanding of the developers series
as a whole um i played a lot of shadow
colossus and aiko is one of my favorite
games of all time
and those games are also
very
they're all in the same vein which is
environmental
based puzzles where your goal is not
always clearly defined
i remember vividly i told peter this we
were talking about the game that i hated
ico for the first two hours i hated it
um i couldn't wrap my mind around i
didn't understand what it was trying to
tell me to do i was really confused
and i think it was almost like a switch
in my brain like learning another
language when i started to realize
this is the puzzle the puzzle is
figuring out what i do next and how i
deal with these situations these
frustrations so in aiko like you're
constantly pulling this girl that can
seem really frustrating that you're
constantly just helping this helpless
girl this is a part of the bonding
experience between this character
similarly uh in in this game when when
you're talking to to trico and he's not
listening you can easily get frustrated
and say obviously like this game isn't
doing what i want it to do
but it's really more about
coming to terms with the fact that you
don't always get what you want sometimes
this is because uh you haven't done it
the correct way you haven't
talked to him you haven't coaxed him
sometimes you're actually doing the
wrong thing and you just haven't come to
terms with that yet you haven't realized
that you actually need to go through a
different corridor in order to get him
to be propped up on the correct
pillar that you need
so this is about experimentation it is a
bit of trial and error but most
importantly i think it's about
exploration both of your environments
and figuring out what you're working
with where you're meant to go and both
exploration of yourself and this
character that you're dealing with
it's amazing
to me i i can get frustrated too and i
did there were times when i was like i
don't know what to do tricho you're
being a real butt head right now he's
just scratching his ear i know i'm
supposed to jump up here
i often found that it was something i
was doing um and that's really
reflective right when you get frustrated
with someone and then you realize
oh yeah it was it was me
um i find that i
uh i find these games really meditative
and really reflective on who i am i want
to be the kind of person that um
that listens and then uses that to to
progress the next area i think this game
is very rewarding
in that aspect that's why i wanted to
play it again yeah and that was sort of
the the takeaway at the end of my review
is that
having learned to care so much about
trico and remembering all the times that
i was just belligerent because i wasn't
letting
i just didn't i didn't i took him for
granted basically right i was looking at
him at him as a mechanic rather than
like a companion a prop to get you to a
certain place yeah so so knowing
you know developing the relationship i
did i wanted to go back and do it all
over again right it's like you know you
regret an argument with people you
regret overlooking something or taking
anyone for granted and you want to
change it and like that's how i felt
about this game and so going back and
starting over was like
one i got to hang out with him again
which is awesome but i got to also feel
like i'm going to be a better friend
this time i'm going to figure out
how i can give trico what he deserves
because he over the course of the
journey changes
to not only fight for himself
or work for his own interest but to work
for yours and to get past his own
hang-ups to do so
and you grow to appreciate that and you
think man if he can do that for me what
can i do for him
yeah so the focus of the game obviously
and like the major you know asset of it
is the relationship between the boy and
trico um but of course when i think back
on like ego or shadow the colossus
there is an overarching story that isn't
immediately apparent especially in
shadow the colossus like
there's no point in like spoiling or
anything but like stuff happens later on
that kind of sheds light on what you
were doing and gives it new context and
shadow colossus is one of my favorite
games if not my favorite game and i love
that without spoiling anything obviously
was there anything in the last guardian
like
does the story go somewhere or is it
really just focused on this like finite
relationship is there a broader story at
play or like what do you think of that
the narrative in general there is a
broader story it's what you're not given
much to begin with and what you get at
the end is both uh the information that
provides context and then a like the
next step in that journey which is like
the culmination of everything you've
done which seems super interesting uh i
mean like earlier in the show we were
talking to scott and he said like dead
rising and a lot of games are the
opposite right exposition dump right
away so you have context you know you're
doing then just play the game it's like
why 20 hours right whereas this
i'm i'm hoping just like shadow of the
colossus or eco which i both like love
both those games last guardian will
build towards something and kind of lend
context to what i've done and not what
i'm about to do it's a more it's a more
natural way of experiencing something
because in life we don't get primers
ahead of an unexpected event you know
that we have to deal with we just we
meet challenges head on as they come and
we tackle them and yeah yeah yeah
they're notorious you're right for their
world building for taking you to these
unbelievably rich worlds where you don't
really know very much but as the story
progresses you learn that they don't
play by our world's rules and this game
is no exception there's
other rules that you don't know that you
will learn along the way
um that really help
create this rich world that you want to
learn everything about and it kind of
just trickles information to you piece
by piece but it really truly is um a
fascinating world that you want to learn
more about and even when the game is
over like i wish there was so much more
that i could learn it's a really
fascinating area and just like their
previous games i think you'll find
everything you learn about that world is
pretty
pretty interesting yeah i do want to
touch on you know the running joke
lately has been we've been waiting so
long for final fantasy 15 and the last
guardian now like it's a one-two punch
we have both of them in within two weeks
and as a reviewer you don't take the
development process into play with your
opinion of the game right it's
what is the game in itself but i'd be
remiss if we didn't talk quickly about
like
this game has been in development for
just as long as final fantasy 15 if not
a little bit a little bit long less
longer like almost a decade maybe yeah
it's super yeah roughly it's like it's i
don't even know like what i want to ask
but it's just crazy that we have this in
our hands finally and like you know it
started its life as a ps3 game you know
like shadow colossus kind of like closed
out the ps2 life cycle like
i don't know what's it like do you think
like this feels like a ps4 game in total
or
does it show that this
began its life so long ago or if you
didn't know that would you notice uh
right no if i didn't know that i don't
think i would notice there's not many
artifacts in the game that i can look at
and say oh yeah that's clearly evidence
of like this project's beginning phase
or something like that final fantasy 15
you could look at and you could say yeah
i see like the two different phases of
this game in one game that's tied
together decent enough
uh but but the magic behind uh
um i was about to say shout out to the
colossus last guardian i think is
evident uh
because the ps4 is able to actually
give life to something like trico where
it's not just you know an image of
feathers painted on his body every
feather moves independently on his body
and that just like really like adds to
the realism of the character which is so
important because it's not just the way
he behaves it is the way he looks as
well um
and i don't believe that that that the
tech of the playstation 3 could have
handled all that independent what seems
to be physics-based animation
um
and yeah like there are a few scenes
that that do have some slowdown and so
like but even those scenes don't have
it's like more like lighting than
anything else so like i'd be shocked to
see what this game looked like on
playstation 3. yeah i don't think
there's any way it would have worked you
know you look at some of the scenes that
are later on you're talking about like
vast open vistas can you read that yeah
if there's like pop in you lose it yeah
you can see like things really far off
in the distance important things
sometimes where they're trying to hint
at things and um really fine thin wires
that you're kind of um precariously
balancing on and all that stuff um in
these giant open scenes with
incredible lighting effects and some of
the best uh if i've i've ever seen grass
and leaves in a game
yeah that are just incredible with the
way they move with the wind i mean
you're not just talking about uh you
know chico is something to be commended
uh i think that's true but in general i
think this is
one of the most beautiful games um
that's like out it is
it's just stunning what they've done to
it and i think it could have only been
on the ps4 at this point awesome yeah so
that's the last guardian finally in our
hands after about 10 years but pete
brown's full review is up on
gamespot.com he gave it a 9 out of 10.
he loved this game despite a few
frustrations but you know the year is
almost over and this is one seems like
it's very well worth playing uh you can
go read the full review and leave your
thoughts in the comments below
mary thanks so much for coming on the
rare occasion that we have the pleasure
of course of course i will uh see you
guys later good luck with your report
cards yeah we're starting end of the
year discussions right now yeah it'll be
good all right
yeah
we're gonna get into uh
yeah we have enough about another hour
left still oh wow
uh yeah bringing on jimmy thang we're
gonna talk about virtual reality this
thing that is not so like uh in the
distant future anymore it has been
happening we might be in it now
oh my god that's what
it does to you rob handler was just like
played an hour of it he came over to my
desk he's like dude that was way too
much vr it was crazy but it was like two
months like what like couple hours like
three is like no like one before he even
told me it was vr i thought he had like
food poisoning or something else like he
looked like
he saw a ghost like he looked messed up
stumbling around like that pillar behind
my
desk dinner please rob what did you just
do in the back room but yeah so all
right so just to outline quickly the
rest of the episode um we're gonna go
like we're gonna do almost every
platform we're not gonna get into like
3ds or vita or anything we're just going
to do vr pc wii u xbox one ps4 and we're
gonna kind of dive into uh overall how
the year unfolded for each of these
platforms and i'm bringing on like our
in-house experts on each platform um
these are not indicative of our final
thoughts like we're not we can't talk
about game of the year awards yet we're
still we are starting our second meeting
for those right after the lobby ends
today we're getting into like you know
top 25 games each platform with the best
ones on each r right now this is just
kind of a discussion a general
discussion that's gonna supplement our
more in-depth report cards as we call
them um and so yeah let's just dive into
vr right now jimmy uh this year from my
understanding uh and from a lot of
people i think you know like last year
things started releasing uh this year
was psvr htc vive and the oculus rift
all officially launched uh
you know it's kind of almost the year
that these things broke through the door
and now you're seeing vr everywhere
whereas like you know there's there's
always like skeptics and i'm sure there
still are but i don't know myself and i
think a lot more people around the
office and i think a lot more of our
audience just kind of like okay it's
here to stay like where do we go from
here is that like is that kind of your
impression too or am i just kind of
alone there or what sure i think uh that
sorry
like prior to 2016 everybody thought or
like some analysts thought that 2016
would be the the year of vr uh i think
in my eyes that's not quite the case
it's more like a slow burn than like a
quick explosion kind of thing
um and yeah as you mentioned we saw the
release of all the major you know hmds
the head mounted displays
and um yeah i mean there's
you know start it started off with the
oculus rift
i think that
platform had a really rocky launch um
but they just
recently released the their touch
controllers which get your hands into vr
and i feel like they've been able to
finish the year strong
um you know early on they had some hmd
shipment issues they had component
shortages
so even if you like pre-ordered or like
back the uh the kickstarter uh you
didn't receive it until like multiple
months later right they also like
encountered a bunch of uh negative press
from like drm issues and things like
that things that they've backed off on
um but
now that touch is here i think they've
made up for a lot of things um
and yeah rob as you mentioned rob was
playing some of those games earlier
today
i find them to be really fun um i think
he was playing like super hot vr yeah um
which is
a game that's redesigned for vr it's
different from the base game and you
feel like
uh you feel like neo from the matrix in
it uh you know things like slow down you
can dodge bullets
um you can shoot enemies and then like
their guns will fly in the air you can
catch them in midair and shoot them back
right
um so that game is really fun and then
uh you know hot on its heels the htc
vive released and that was the first
vr platform to allow you to like walk
around in sort of a room scale
environment
um
and that was 800 but it it is the most
sophisticated vr uh tracking system
and uh
most the games that released on that
platform i would admit as a vr
enthusiast i would admit that most of
them are shovelware yeah but there are
several diamonds in the rough um i think
uh the onward is really good a bunch of
early access stuff uh raw data is really
fun as well sure yeah i mean like htc
was my favorite during preview events
because it actually kind of made use of
the space around you i think what are
they called the chaperones that kind of
outline the chaperone system um i don't
know like uh i mean we haven't talked
too much about psvr yet but sure yeah of
all these platforms do you have a
favorite or are they kind of like
obviously like as competitors they kind
of offer something different right yeah
seems the most accessible one i think
they have their strengths and advantages
you know psvr it's it's the least robust
perhaps out of the three
but it is you know the most accessible
it's it starts at 399 dollars
um and
um it does a pretty good you know it you
know it's the cheapest thing but in my
opinion it punches above its weight
class um a bit considering it's price
tag
and uh yeah peter and i talked about it
a little bit and i think
before
i would have like said
in my personal opinion that the best vr
headset is the vive
um but the
the rift with touch i feel like it's
much closer now sure and i feel like
maybe the rift
has slightly better controllers
but the vive has
uh better tracking the better tracking
system yeah the oculus touch it kind of
like brings that more tactile feel to
the vr which is something like you're
never we're talking about resident evil
7 and how the fact that you know
obviously it's vr this is an obvious
thing when they touch you you're not
going to feel in the real world unless
it's like something vibrating or if it's
something that you're holding that's
gonna react to it sure but the oculus
touch i felt like that was much more of
an actual uh you know like again like
this like kinetic thing that i was using
whereas you know the htc vive the
remotes and the ps the playstation
remotes didn't really do it for me yeah
so like i think the um the touch
controllers are
they represent your hands more whereas
the ps like the playstation move
and the vive they're more abstract
they're more like things that you hold
so it's like
with the vive wands it's like you're
holding a gun or you're holding a sword
whereas the touch is more like these are
your hands yeah um and there's like
quasi finger tracking so you can like
point and you can like give the thumbs
up gesture and things like that sure um
which help in like co-op games like hey
look at that or like nice job and and so
forth yeah i do want to get into you
know like the game libraries there's the
software that these are supporting and
vice versa but um
yeah like i don't know like there are
some that we like we seem to have like
different tastes pete you've been liking
a lot of these like third person games
right i mean you mentioned experiences
and stuff yeah like edge of nowhere and
chronos and things like that i like a
like a
you know a broad range i think of these
games but um i have you know and
i used to write off the idea of third
person stuff in vr because i was like
what's the point doesn't
that's not why i'm excited about this
but it turns out that like you know
great gameplay can translate over to vr
and you can benefit in ways
uh you know such as immersion that uh
you know appear in storytelling and
world design and that was the case with
edge of nowhere uh it was also the case
with chronos in an interesting way
because that game uses uses a fixed
camera where every time you enter a new
room the camera is positioned in one
place or another think the original
resident evil right um
but your head is the camera in that in
that regard which i found super
fascinating because i'm a big fan of
that old style
um so it might not be the most
compelling use of the new technology but
i thought it definitely elevated uh what
was there already
um but you know again i think a lot of
it comes down to the platform like i've
used touch and vive uh
you know in this sort of like small room
scale settings and i gotta agree with
you like i like the rift better in that
regard um and you know like the vibe is
just so hard to set up
it's such a pain in the butt like i've
gotten so close to tracing the space
like in my home and it's like oh you're
one inch off and it's like i don't care
about that one inch you care but let me
freakin play the game
so i find it hard there's the barrier to
entry for me to play five games is
higher whereas for rift and playstation
vr it's very simple you know in a lot of
ways um but longevity is also a thing
too and wearing the playstation vr
headset it's super comfortable
it is the most comfortable headset yeah
to see see the other companies go for
maybe the higher specs where sony
focused in on value but then they also
were able to nail uh just the ease of
the use and comfort that's pretty great
so sometimes that can dictate what type
of game i want to experience
um i feel like there's there's like a
there would be like an awesome headset
if you can like combine their best
aspects like right playstation vr's um
comfort uh the vives tracking in like
the oculus rifts like controllers that
would be that would be like perfect i
know yeah
that's what i played a few preview
events and the defense grid 2 that tower
defense game had this really cool like
it would give you it's being a tower
defense game you know you have a set
path and there's these minions coming
through that you're defending against
and i didn't even think about this but
then once i played i was like that makes
sense in vr which is like i guess a lot
of these experiences once you actually
experience it it makes sense but you
know you have this god like bird's eye
view of uh
the grid itself and then you can kind of
just look down instead of having to
scroll through i keep waiting for more
people to do like large-scale rts games
yeah they're coming like xcom xcom 2 i
think sure being one of them strategy
games are amazing in vr you basically
play as god and control you you have to
scroll the screen you literally you're
just above it you look down you can
instead of like pressing a bumper or
pressing like e to
rotate the map you just look around a
corner like actually physically look
around it point to where you want these
guys to go like pick them up and drag
them i can't wait for more like things
like that you said they're coming uh
yeah i can't wait for that because those
are like my most anticipated experiences
yeah i think there's a
wide variety of games like as you
mentioned like third-person games that
that work
that i would argue you could have it on
a traditional tv but that are more
immersive in vr i think like thumper and
rez like satisfy those uh requirements
as well like those games can be played
on tv but playing thumper in vr is much
more immersive
dude it's um yeah
it's hard to communicate until you try
it but if you've if you've ever want to
feel overwhelmed in like the best way
possible play thumper in vr yeah it
feels it feels like apocalyptic but in a
very cool
strong way yeah it's like you're on the
front of a bullet train and it's just
speeding ahead a thousand miles an hour
and a monster is staring at you like
it's crazy
yeah i'm looking i am looking forward to
next year from what i see a lot of the
games that i've had fun with a lot of
people are having fun with and this is
not a catch-all thing i feel like the
games that we're praising a lot of them
are the ones that kind of hide the
limitations of vr at this point like
like thumper like it's cool it gives you
a really good view but i feel like we're
we still haven't hit that point where a
lot of like we're seeing vr's full
potential and i'm sure it's not gonna
happen right away yeah i think uh rob
was playing uh room in a chair which is
a game that sharing a room
i always yeah i always say that i don't
know why the other one would be more
impressed yeah but um that's a game that
uses room scale so basically the
environments are all very small
room-like environments and if you have a
room like that's big enough then um
then you don't need to like teleport or
anything like that so it just works uh
within the constraints of the game yeah
and does it have horror aspects to it
from what i understand yeah okay
yeah it's a horror game okay and that's
what
the resident evil 7 is coming out and
has full psvr sport and you can actually
just do a play through regular on a flat
screen and then you can reload that
checkpoint or go from the next save next
time you play in vr i'm excited for that
because you have to dedicate one play
through and commit to vr or if you
really like vr you have to commit to
like you know a single screen play
through um i
as a big fan of horror games i
still haven't played anything that
really impresses me in the genre try to
try this game i think what it does well
is that it takes advantage of what vr
can do so like you might turn your head
around and all of a sudden the scene
changes and you're like what is going on
but the game is about like how you're
like a psych patient you're going crazy
and are things real you don't know
and vr messes with your head
appropriately
in that space so overall what are your
two takes i mean jimmy you wrote the
report card for vr i don't think it's up
yet it will be up soon or is it i'm in
the process of writing cool so it'll be
up soon that'll be like more in-depth
thoughts from jimmy but um i don't know
in general
i think it was pretty good yeah i think
it's it's not uh it wasn't going to
explode on the scene like um
like you know the wii did but i think
it's more of a slow burn and i think it
has a bright feature out of it yeah pete
you've been optimistic about vr for a
while and it seems like your uh your
suspicions and your expectations are
proving fruitful
uh yeah i mean i think it's definitely
landed like it's here i don't hear
skeptics anymore like i don't feel like
there is that loud segment of the
audience being like vr is stupid no one
wants it i think
at this point everyone can look at it
and say yeah i've heard this one thing
as rad or i played this one thing and
it's really rad like everyone has a
touchstone now where they care about vr
one way or another uh and if you look at
something like google earth vr have you
tried that not yet no but it's amazing
but that's the thing is everyone says
that yeah so i want to mention quick one
one quick thing about that um
so that's an app that was made by google
that takes the google earth api and then
they like retrofitted it to work in vr
but it feels to me like it was built for
vr
and
you know i was reading on on reddit and
things like that like grown men
put it on
they like fly to like where they grew up
as a kid and they sit on like their old
rooftops and they would just start
crying um because it's just like a
nostalgia machine yeah and and i was
like that's very interesting i put it on
i did the same thing and i got very
nostalgic and yeah kind of talk about
virtual reality right i mean that's
it's not just pain giving us a fantastic
world it's replicating i think what you
know the dream is is that something is
so convincing right and what is more
convincing than reality and and this has
sort of achieved that in in a way that
hits you know the threshold is is hit
and so we get there that's that's not
how good it looks is it yeah it is holy
[ __ ] so it's not um it's not fake um
right so all the stuff is actually real
rendered from like satellites yeah and
you can actually zoom out and see uh the
earth in outer space and look up at all
the stars around you and they're real
they're not like computer drawings
they're actually like real life um
that's insane photo telemetry man i
really need to try that out yeah so when
you see something like this i think
there's no way you can be cynical about
vr right and this came in the first year
of this wave yeah dude give it five
years give it 20 years right like yeah i
don't think anyone can be cynical about
that damn all right cool well
uh you know things seem to be looking up
for vr so i'm optimistic about it i
still have a lot of games to play this
is the first year we've had like an
actual vr category for end of the year
if i'm not mistaken last year again it
was still burgeoning so it seems like
it's you know starting to like you said
slow burn so
looking forward to that if you are
watching this after we record it live
our
vr report card should be up on site as
of now so you can go read jimmy's more
in-depth thoughts on gamespot.com
cool jimmy thanks so much for coming on
thanks for having me we're gonna get uh
justin on here talk about the wii u
uh a year that we'll we'll get into it
uh man do we have
google earth vr in the office yeah yeah
on sure
or sorry i think it just works
let's double check like i said i haven't
used it yet cool but it's it's free i
think justin what's up how's it going i
think everybody has google earth vr
because
we have two eyes when i go out on the
street that's google earth vr so just
before you enter i'm sure you heard and
maybe this is what you're counter
pointing pizza there are no skeptics
left for vr is that what you're doing is
that the shtick right now
i don't think this is the year for vr i
i think the future of vr is still bright
but
the jury is still out on whether it was
this is the year for it well no it's not
it's not this year well let's get into
something which it definitely was the
year for
nintendo's wii u console what are you
talking about
so we had to because of the lack of
releases this year uh our like category
on wii u is pretty sparse for our end of
the year awards we left out tons of very
important wii u games uh re-releases of
of games like minecraft the minecraft
finally coming to wii u uh
mario and sonic at the rio olympic
winter game real logic summer games
the
nameless other game names games that i
could name endlessly
all right it doesn't even know how to
speak because there's not a lot all
right so i do we can talk about the few
games that did come out um i do want to
talk about kind of you know like it's
kind of tough not to talk about the
nintendo switch announcement and
nintendo switches impending release i
know in the coming months we'll get more
news about it but
it does make sense now that the wii u's
life cycle is just effectively
ending it's coming to a close and
nintendo switch is on the horizon
finally it's not the nx anymore pete and
i were both lamenting that
the nx yeah i mean like i called the wii
the revolution for a while and then i
finally came around but hopefully the nx
will stick more in my mind but justin
tell me about this uh
again this new console like we see the
announcement trailer right here showing
dude playing zelda wii u
a very confusing trailing trailer
followed like everything you can do with
it not confusing it makes sense but just
the amount of different ways you could
play this console
i do want to touch on that quick uh how
how's this going to change like how we
play nintendo games or like ideally how
would it based on what we've seen of
itself from the trailer
it almost seems like it's a an
all-in-one console that this is both
your home console and something that's
going to replace the 3ds and i think
nintendo has has come out
and at least talked around that saying
that the 3ds is still going to live on
its own that this doesn't
supersede the 3ds as a platform as the
handheld system that's what investors
want to hear though because it's their
best-selling thing they're not going to
say we're going to kill our best-selling
thing for a bet well i i they're not
going to kill their best-selling thing
for a bit like we still have 2017 with
some good 3ds titles on the horizon and
who knows how much longer it's going to
last beyond that but you have a budget
price system
there are rumors that the switch could
come in at 200 which like that itself
would be a game changer but right now
the 3ds is kind of the budget system
it's really friendly for kids it has a
long battery life and i think it has a
lot of positives that something like
just being more powerful doesn't
necessarily make a handheld system
better like look at vita like despite
being an excellent system with a really
great set of games you can play the
entire library of playstation 1 classics
and the games that you do play on it
look 100 better than 3ds and it was
stomped by the 3ds just because of its
library the the library
titles but i think there were a lot of
things that went into it like when it
came out it was more expensive that 3ds
you were able to manufacture for it
faster
and just the people don't want
a handheld experience that's going to be
what you get on console like as much as
i think like playing breath of the wild
is going to be really fun i can go out
in the park and do like no i don't want
to go in the park and play breath of the
wild but breath of the wild is a game
that i'm gonna play in my living room at
home like and the games that i play on
the go when i'm on the bus like those
are different experiences and they have
to be made to be different i have to be
able to close them quickly to be able to
save anywhere i want and be able to get
in and out of that gameplay quickly
which is a strength of the 3ds and
something
we're talking about the wii u but
something that the wii u never quite
also found its niche it never found its
thing that separated that that made it a
compelling thing to buy separately from
but the other gamepad justin
the gamepad was a mistake
i think it was a good idea that both
came too late and wasn't the right thing
like the switch is what i thought i like
i remember seeing the wii u's reveal
when it when it first came out and
you're like oh my god they're making a
portable tablet nintendo console and
like oh no actually this is tethered to
your your living room you you really
can't even go to the bathroom without
losing your connection and the battery
dies in like an hour and a half so yeah
it's just so like the tech is just so
low on that thing and that's the only
reason the system costs as much as it
does
like it's not a powerful console it has
a bad peripheral that you have to use
and games like star fox
like you feel like nintendo is cramming
this thing down your throat yeah when
everyone is just like please please get
rid of it please don't do this and
they're like guess what we don't care in
like the last year of its life cycle
they're still trying to promote this
tech i feel like they you know the wii
finally
nailed it with like skyward sword or
something and forget how long into that
that was before the wii u but well we
saw them arguing with themselves this
year especially with the wii that we saw
things like star fox where you're forced
to use motion controls that don't work
that that is not the best way to play
this game but you also have have games
like donkey kong where or or other
experiences where that controller the
screen does nothing it's just a blank
black screen if you want to play it
portably onto the wii u screen you could
do that but
it was almost nintendo admitting like uh
yeah we're going to be making
experiences that don't require both
screens and we know this ahead of time
so like but for all intents and purposes
the wii u is
almost done like i mean the wild is
still going to come out on wii u so
there's something to look forward to but
this year has been a bit i i would
definitely say abysmal at the beginning
of the year we had smash but we had an
update for smash brothers the last two
characters not the the most important
but the most interesting but
i mean that's the thing like the most
exciting things for the console were for
a game that came out years ago yeah it's
a huge game but if that's one of the
highlights of a year i think something
was up i mean it doesn't seem like last
year what do we have with the wii u's uh
splatoon there's a few last year correct
oh it's like more um mario maker was
fantastic i think that was like our
number five game wasn't it it was up
there it's pretty high and that's one of
like my favorite things in the wii u i
don't know like looking back over the
entire lifespan of the wii u i don't
want to just i'm not hating on it i
enjoy the experiences i played but i
don't think i played more than like 15
games total on the console throughout
its lifespan i just if i went to it was
because i absolutely had to and i
enjoyed those like i said but i just
don't feel like maybe that's why i'm so
optimistic about the switch despite you
know still questions that are lingering
i
feel like i hope this is when they turn
it around right i mean like this year
was pretty good for xbox one compared to
past years and i think maybe the scorpio
kind of lent some optimism to that
platform and everything with that on the
horizon i just i don't know looking back
i did not really value the wii u much so
the holistically i think the wii u is
great the wii u has some great
experiences and looking at it year on
year it's not that awesome but
there is not involved there is another
console where you can play mario maker
it's the 3ds you can get a [ __ ] version
of mario maker on that but super mario
3d world mario kart splatoon uh the hd
versions of the legend of zelda twilight
princess and uh not spirit tracks uh
wind waker yeah like these are great
experiences to have on the wii u and to
be able to play in your living room
earthbound like finally getting to
download that and play that on a console
better on 3ds but like there there are a
lot of great reasons to own a wii u but
it's definitely just kind of petered out
in this last year of its life that this
was not the way for me
it just kind of just out like yeah it
approached the end of its life now
justin it means awesome things
it's totally you know it hits like xbox
is coming into its justin
i think nintendo kind of hit the peak of
being a stubborn company who wants to
to show people how innovative they are
when no one's asking for innovation i
think they got really lucky with with
the wii i don't think
oh i don't think they may have known how
successful that thing would have been um
and that worked out really really well
you know uh but the gamepad i don't
understand what they were trying to do
if they were trying to to latch on to
okay tablets are a thing touch screens
are a thing
they went about it in the sloppiest way
possible i think that's what it was it
was them saying mobile games are really
popular instead of making mobile games
let's make our own system that has
mobile interface right let's take away
why people play mobile games and just
have people try to play mobile games in
front of their tv right but yeah like it
was yeah it was creating a hurdle that
that no one has to be put up and i think
that's what's great about the switch is
that there doesn't seem to be this thing
where it's like i don't understand this
about it i don't understand that there
is something special it's a convertible
system
but beyond that doesn't actually impact
the games that you're playing where
nintendo had a really good habit of
getting in front of the games they were
playing with something that you didn't
really care about or asked for and so
many things didn't live up to their full
potential i mean when you talk about the
hardware the tech itself but also a huge
push into the toys for life genre with
amiibo
and outside of smash brothers and having
this huge roster of smash brothers
amiibo and kind of animal crossing even
though there's
not much else you can do with it like
there's just not that much amiibo and
very little you can actually do with
them yeah they're best is just figurines
yeah they're really cool
nice high quality figurines that
i know i don't even like using them in
games that that require that use them
mario party was i think an excellent
example of a game that used amiibo in
the worst way imaginable hasbro makes
really cool figurines as well
do you don't want figurines from
nintendo just
games i want like we've got what looks
to be one of the
best zeldas like we can't speak to that
yet we've all played like a few hours of
it but
i you know like hopefully like i feel
like if they just announced a new
metroid on twitch like i just want them
to get back to that stuff like this i'm
not the only person this is nothing new
and revelatory that i'm hoping for this
uh i just i don't know i want them to
focus on
feel like they're in the right direction
with a switch and i hope they just nail
it come whenever they release it then we
didn't get i this is obviously near the
last i think next year will be the last
year for the wii u 100 the switch is
coming out
and we went through an entire console
lifecycle without experiences that
especially fans have been craving like
metroid there was new no new zelda for
the wii u until right now at the very
end mother 3 everybody's asking for it
never came out yeah all right well i do
want to touch on i want to kind of
rattle through some of the games this
year that we didn't mention you
mentioned twilight princess remastered
uh again it's a remaster it's re-release
of the wii
of the gamecube wii title uh it was
great which is a launch title like that
i think that helped also catapult sales
of the the wii yeah uh star fox zero p
you reviewed it didn't speak too highly
of it has its moments yeah it can be
cool at times but it's uh
doesn't play the way a star fox game
should and i and i hate to say it that
way but that's kind of the truth because
they present you with a thing that is
like you remember old star fox right
here are very familiar scenarios but you
have to play them very differently it
didn't work out paper mario color splash
it's cute it and it's a it's another one
of those where you kind of have that
same
experience that you expect to get out of
it and nintendo regurgitates things
really well they make these games very
fun to play but you can also only
revisit that well so many times and
mario color splash it's it's fine it's a
very serviceable mario rpg but that's
not what people wanted
pokken tournament
that's a really cool game and i feel
like the wii u is probably the reason
it's not talked about more yeah because
i don't see if i mean i guess smash duh
but i don't really see a big fighting
game community on the wii u and i feel
like pokken maybe smack well i mean
smash does have a good fighting
community behind it but pokken was like
it's a very different game you know um i
think more of a traditional fighting
game right closer to it yeah like in
spirit and i think uh that was just
maybe lost on people like it was great
and then it kind of went away and like
people stopped talking about it yeah um
yeah i feel like it was wasted on the
wii u seeing blaziken here makes me
nostalgic for pokemon x and y he wasn't
in he wasn't in sun and moon i haven't
gotten that far right all right anyway
uh all right help me out the name of
this there's a hashtag in it
so
tokyo mirage sessions sharp fe thank you
i knew what it was i just wanted you to
feel cool saying i just i i wanted to be
the embarrassing one
which we've had i i think that is also a
strength of the wii u that it has been a
champion of really great japanese-based
rpgs like these experiences that fans
had had wanted for a long time um
xenoblade chronicles or xenoblade
chronicles x yeah yeah and amaze
[Music]
was also a beautiful fun experience and
like that's that is fan service for
those people who love that kind of game
yeah so again kind of a disappointing
year for the wii u but i mean it's it's
nearing the end of its life and we are
anticipating eagerly the nintendo switch
so we will have more news on that in the
coming months
hopefully i'm sure and uh you know once
it releases rising from the ashes yeah
let's hope we'll all burn our wii u's
and then they'll turn into uh switches
yeah we're all rooting for nintendo
let's just hope they pull it off uh if
you're watching this live it's not up
yet but you can watch
you can read justin's more in-depth wii
u end of the report card on gamespot if
you're watching this on youtube or the
site you can't because i didn't write it
no i'm sorry oscar deus in the uk uh
we'll have that published as of your
viewing right now on youtube or
gamespot.com
mark thanks justin thank you i just want
to call him dr zaius who's that oscar
deus
cause i feel like i can just switch
those oh yeah people people do like beat
her proud sure yeah
mine's pretty dumb it's just the same
thing
all right anyway ah i'm getting into uh
all right the pc uh end of the year
review
michael hyam you have been writing that
again if you're watching this live it's
not up yet but if you're watching this
on youtube or gamespot it'll be up
as of this viewing uh so this year was i
mean every year it seems like it's
really good for people who play games on
pc pc gamers as it were
uh i by myself have become increasingly
into pc games but uh a lot of things
happened this year uh tell us like it
seems more cost effective
than ever to own a pc and play games on
it if i'm not mistaken can you talk
about that a little bit with like new
graphics cards and new kind of like i
don't know customizable pc options yeah
if we're talking about hardware um the
pc hardware is the
graphics cards cpus like ssds have been
about the same price with every
iteration but the boost you get in
performance from the previous generation
is like
it's getting better and better and
better so especially
if you're because most people are still
gaming on 1080p
so i mean if you're gonna be gaming in
1080p and you have like a 1070 you're
gonna be able to max out everything
pretty much i mean the witcher 3 if you
go back to last year looks great and
runs well a lot of games in 2016 have we
can get into this later but uh some
performance problems but
the games that do run well you can max
that out even i'm playing doom 3 which
came out this year i'm still on a 970
and i'm maxing that out and it runs
incredibly well so if you go to 1440p or
if you even want to try 4k with uh with
hardware
and graphics cards that came out this
year uh it's possible so and that's
that's bright uh the future is bright
for pc hardware and you know 2016 is a
showcase of that yeah i remember like
midway through this year maybe when uh
what were the what were the graphics
cards that got announced were like holy
[ __ ] that price for that was that the
gtx
1060 was the first one that was like
shocking the i think the 1070 was
probably the like the boldest statement
now the the 1070 msrp was around 400 but
it was outperforming the 980 ti which is
right the super duper dope
so like previous generation it also
seems like a year when people who might
have been on the cusp of like i don't
know how to build a pc i don't know what
i need myself i don't i don't i'm not
that knowledgeable when it comes to
stuff but this is the year i actually
started looking into it it felt much
more like it was even more accessible
because it's the it's not the most
accessible platform at all that's why
consoles are appealing to so many people
you have what you have i think scott
butterworth wants to use the uh like a
metaphor like a console is kind of an
apartment you rent and like when you get
a pc it's more of a house
you own it but it also you have to take
care of it a lot more and your
landlord's not going to maintain it for
you i think it was scott that sounds
like a scott metaphor and it works
because i don't actually have to like
with a console this is obvious i don't
have to worry about all that stuff but
this year was the one where i first
started approaching it actually being
like oh i can get into this and that's
what like those announcements and
everything and like speaking to you
speaking of peter speaking to jimmy it
just seems like it's easier than ever to
build a pc that's like right for me yeah
especially with tools like pc part
picker um it's very in everyone talking
on like pc gaming centric forums it's
they it boils down to just picking out
the parts and then building your pc is
like playing with lego blocks
essentially you just put it into place
you boot it up you might have a problem
like peter had earlier the last time my
power supply died yeah
it's no fault of my own it happens it
happens man i don't know what i tell you
but yeah it's a reality you have to face
sometimes these things will kick the
bucket because you are taking components
from all manner of manufacturers
and uh that's a lot of variables some
things might go wrong yeah it's tough to
look back over the past year and just
say this was consigned this year because
it always seems like developers have
trouble every once in a while porting
games to pc i mean last year i think the
biggest one that stood out was arkham
knight because
it was so vastly different on pc it was
broken for a while and i remember like
people like had to like specifically
review it on pc because it was so bad
but
uh there were a few bad ports this year
and you know it's tough again to point
that out because it's like a
case-by-case basis like you don't i
don't i'm not a developer i don't know
everything that goes into like
considering all the hardware that these
games have to run on and whatnot and
what like the specs would be whereas
again the console's set uh we like we
looked at mafia three was kind of uh not
performing crazy well in pc dishonored 2
for a really recent one i think is still
has an ongoing problems when we're
talking about that as opposed to its
performances on xbox one and ps4 but i
believe in the like the report card that
you're working on you mentioned a few
questionable ports can you talk about
that yeah so you mentioned dishonored 2
and mafia 3. the thing though is that
it's it's frustrating for pc gamers like
i'm going to drop this money on a
computer and i want it to run well uh
and you get that for the most part but
when high profile games like dishonored
tune uh especially i know rob was
talking about how he has like a decked
out computer and he's having trouble
with frame drops and the thing with with
that is that they're inexplicable when
they happen
uh and
like you'll be in a certain space and
you'll be getting a good 60 plus and
then you'll be turning to another space
that isn't that graphically different
and then you'll drop to like 40 or 30.
and it's like why did that happen and
it's it's tough to figure out so then
you have to wait for you know post
release patches for them to figure that
kind of stuff out
and when you compare it to consoles it's
like
on consoles you're going to get like 30
and some frame drops maybe
uh and but on pc when you're when you're
bouncing between 60 plus and then down
to 40 and back to 60 plus and back to 40
and 30 it's it's jarring when you play
it so it's like when i'm on the muni and
like the bus drivers like stop and go
stop and go like that that throws you
off and that's kind of like how it is
with performance issues in these games
right
so once i mean
you can only hope for a
patch that will help that sort of
problem so i can make the game a little
bit more playable so i it's it happens
2016 there was a lot of instances of
that uh and i hope that 2017 would be
better but i don't know and it's still
the case where we see like when a new
big game comes out for pc there have to
be new drivers issued yeah you know what
i mean like what a weird relationship
for the technology and software to have
sure it is frustrating because i mean
like it seems like a lot of times pc
gamers kind of or the release date for
the game is you know like december 6th
but for pc players it's really like
december 21st or something i don't know
yeah for instance it's unfortunate
because they have to just keep waiting
out and like reading developer blog
posts where i'm sure the developers are
trying to figure out just as hard i
don't know what goes on behind the
scenes but it's unfortunate
but uh i don't know i do want to get
into the software um
because there were a lot of good pc
games like pc focused or just like pc
games that were like also on consoles um
the first one i want to talk about as
one of my favorite games of the year and
it is on ps4 and xbox one but it's also
like it's home is on pc or at least i
think so overwatch i think you know
we've been playing this uh you know
early access before it released on pc
for a while pc is where all these like
you know that's where i go for like the
halloween events and the christmas
events and whatnot and you know it's a
as a traditional shooter player i prefer
mouse and keyboard and controller um
overwatch like blizzard nailed it again
you know they step into a new genre and
they just kind of figure out what makes
it tick and they put their own take on
it and you know this is i think this is
the best hero shooter there is for like
a you know like a sub genre whatever you
want to call it that has exploded in
recent months and years uh i don't know
are you a big overwatch player yeah i
play a lot of overwatch i had it for ps4
and pc because a lot of my homies play
on ps4 but it's like you said it's home
is on the pc because of how fast and
how precise you have to be with certain
characters it works well on console
because of the abilities adapt well to a
controller
but like the competitive play like if
you're serious about competition
especially when
blizzard and overwatch are trying to
establish like the overwatch league for
making like a legit esport with like
regions and cities and yeah that sounds
so cool to me there's like a a fan of
traditional sports that just is really
appealing to me i'd be super into like
i don't want to make up that's the
mascot the san francisco
slayers
when we're done throwing up let's get
back into overwatch uh anyway i started
interrupting oh no it's all good man but
like suggestion but
but yeah the the overwatch league it's
gonna take over on pc but just because
like the level of play is much higher
and
uh that's the type of game that you want
to play on pc
yeah i mean like a another huge year for
just firaxis in general two of my
favorite franchises civ six came out uh
scott barter with reviewed it gave it a
nine out of ten says it's it's one of
the best like you know like these games
are changed with their expansions five
after gods and kings and brave new world
became
what civ five could have been and like
it's perfect like it's perfected vision
uh version once that was released six
scott like called it and i agree the
best initial release in this series ever
uh you know like a lot of people were
giving it [ __ ] for being like cartoony
looking and kind of
like they were trying to make it more
accessible i don't think that's the case
i think like by expanding these cities
you know you can go you can go for hours
and we've done this before into like
what has changed but
i don't know for like just the next
numbered entry in the civ series is one
of my favorites and i i played a lot of
it i want to play more but i was too
busy playing another fractious game
which we can get into but yeah six i
don't know did you guys get the chance
to play this cause this like it released
kind of right before that huge rush of
like battlefield 1 titanfall 2 call of
duty uh
everything that fall release and it was
kind of right before that unfortunately
so i don't think people get to spend as
much time with it i don't know if you
guys devoted too much time to step six i
literally installed it on my pc this
morning so i can play it before we start
to rank yeah
i don't know michael did you get a
chance yeah i played a little bit i
played morris at five than i did six but
i understand how six plays into the
the series of civilization
and how it's a much more complete
package
uh and
i think also if we're going to keep
talking about for axis like xcom 2 i
think is even even it's a bigger step
for the x-com series than civ 6 was for
the civilization series not to say that
they're
either ones better than the other
because they're both like two separate
teams inside for access you know like
jake solomon heading up xcom and then
you know like uh in this case ed beach
just different people rotating through
but yeah same studio but they they they
was on point this year dude yeah like
i wish i hadn't got brought up because i
could talk about it forever but xcom 2
uh that was february it feels crazy long
but now it's on you know like consoles
as well but on pc i mean the ease of use
there were definitely technical hiccups
but
i think fair axis figured out exactly
not just what made x come enemy and
known great but how they could figure
like make a you know a legit sequel that
doesn't just like
push what enemy unknown did but actually
do new things that make you think about
that formula in a way that like that
layered you know rts and then there's
the turn base and then there's the rpg
elements of the individual characters
just those three layers interacting with
each other i this was one of my favorite
games this year it's one of my favorite
games on pc ever i think and
uh it's
this game is unreal and i think if you
have a pc or if you have consoles now
you should play this and try it out yeah
xcom 2 i'm i was a big fan of xcom when
i was like a little kid i watched my
brother play it and that was like super
dope like that was my entrance into like
strategy games yeah so when uh they made
a resurgence with enemy unknown in 2012
i was like oh this is sure this is great
and then so but xcom 2 takes it a step
further and i think that i always felt
like i was on my toes like uh you have
to deal with failure we were talking
about that yesterday yeah
in xcom 2 like you're going to fail at
some point in some way
and you have to move on and learn from
that and it does a good job because then
a lot of games modern games where you
know if you die you just go back to
whatever checkpoint you're in and you
continue on but like xcom 2 like the
consequences of failure are very you
feel them in xcom 2 and you learn from
that and i think that you know not that
maybe more games should do that but if
they do
do that like kind of like almost dark
souls-esque yep yeah that's that is the
comparison and i actually think this
makes failure more meaningful than dark
souls yeah definitely that's probably
controversial but anyway uh world of
warcraft legion another big expansion
that game people are still playing it
after how many years 12 213 yeah i think
you're closer uh it was good it sounds
like they had a new class the demon
hunter uh courtesy of diablo 3 i believe
or just diablo
blizzard lore in general um justin liked
that a lot i think he we ended up
freelance reviewing that yeah yeah uh we
like that owlboy pete you liked it a lot
pc exclusive for now it's coming to
consoles they do have plans to come to
console yeah uh
that was also a while in the making
between the art like just nine years
yeah a lot of this year 2016 was the
game like when final people finally like
sat down to finish these off and
i reviewed them yeah you did apparently
or all i don't even know how many but
yeah oh boy great great experience from
what you tell us super just awesome
characterization of the world through
music and graphics and animations bring
the characters to life with excellent
writing that
uh reveals new sides of them that you
never really saw coming and you didn't
expect the game to go there in some ways
so
another title that
michael you've been championing for
quite a while i'm glad you're here
quickly quadrilateral cowboy why should
we play it uh because it's dope
art style and unique gameplay elements
uh that's and a story you can unravel
for yourself focus on hacking
more real watch dogs
sure
with that like jazz punk kind of looking
yeah yeah if you feel like summary at
all that's not it yeah i feel like jazz
point get that cool people have been
kind of uh people a lot of people are
kind of lamenting the rts
genre
saying it's in decline this year is
actually kind of there are a lot of rts
releases uh on pc i mean deserts of
karak i played a little bit i loved it i
think that game the story actually
itself it's kind of like i play
starcraft games for the story not the
competition deserts of carack if you
want a really good rts story delve into
that uh total war warhammer i think it
took what made total war great it made a
few changes to the total war formula
it's more on a rectangular field if
you're a total war fan you know what i'm
talking about combine it with warhammer
franchise uh you know property a lot of
people like that um there's actually the
singularity which didn't really shape up
but in terms of scale that was really
impressive uh but in general
great year for the pc library and uh
like i said it's the year i finally got
into building pcs and whatnot or at
least like taking the first few
tentative steps into it and kind of more
accessible and vr is a part of it too
yeah i know we talked about vr distance
but but yeah i mean vr pc is the home of
vr cool
anyway uh yeah so michael hi i'm your pc
report card and the report card will be
up on gamespot if you're not watching
this live you can go read that if you're
watching this live that'll be up in the
next few days uh we have these coming up
in the next you know coming weeks and uh
yeah go read that check it out michael
heim thanks so much for coming on thanks
man always great to have you we're gonna
boot you off and uh yeah get into the
last couple of our ever rotating series
of guests today
yeah what are you thinking who's your
favorite guest so far i'm just kidding
i'm gonna start fighting it's always
justin uh so it's always just here's a
here's a fan favorite rob hanlery
i said that it sounded sarcastic when i
said it i think most things do but uh my
life operates on sarcasm
are you a robot fueled by it because
your voice sounded very flat right there
i feel like a robot after playing vr
just now yeah it's like i like still
have part of me in the headset like yeah
i feel like it was like you know
the matrix someone pulling out the chord
and then like putting it back in a
little bit it's just kind of like just
like whoa whoa
it's like ten percent just playing with
it yeah like and then finally cipher
screws you over and then it's exactly
right he gets smoked by dozer um anyway
brought you on to talk about xbox one
end of the year review uh
i think this year was also a big
turnaround for xbox one or at least
again i mentioned this earlier when
you're talking about the wii u the
switch announcement i think the xbox
how do you even say it project scorpio
or xbox project scorpio or xbox scorpio
xbox one scorpio stop stopping xbox and
scorpio right yeah why didn't you stop
me before that i'm gonna keep going all
right so the scorpio was announced uh
and you know like
it from what they've said it's going to
be more powerful than the ps4 pro which
was released which we'll get into in the
last segment today
but i think that lends some optimism but
i think xbox also had
outside of its exclusives a good year in
general i think they made good on
promises i think like you know like
they still i think since it released
they've been trying to
repair the damage they did or at least
like that fans thought they did when
they first announced the console right
with uh with all those like family share
plans and like always online
fiasco
connect which is dead yeah
i know like chris pereira one of our
news editors just like won't ever shut
up about connect i think he's just
lost it no i'm just kidding uh
i don't know i did want to talk about
but with the new with the xbox one s uh
which has released it's not just an
announcement that was released and that
i think just like between the you know
downsizing the xbox one uh in terms of
hardware improvements can you talk about
that are there any are they noticeable
there's some there's some slight
technical upgrades inside that some
developers are quietly taking advantage
of nothing like vastly noticeable um
but it was the first console that came
to uh with hdr which now playstation has
as well it was sort of enabled with a
firmware update after the slim
uh after the pros launched either way
but uh yeah the 1s is just a super
handsome looking xbox it doesn't seem
like this big bulky thing that you're
trying to cram somewhere the vcr right
and it's also like one of the first and
like the cheapest standalone uhd you
know 4k blu-ray players yeah which the
playstation 4 pro came out sony is one
of the pioneers of the blu-ray format
and they don't even have that in their
system and their top-end console doesn't
even have it right which is super weird
super weird figure out why i don't want
to get too much into sony stuff uh i
i feel like someone brought up a good
point i mean i can't i can't recall
because microsoft stole it from them and
brought it to their laboratory and
crafted the xbox one s holding back
for like the next no i don't think i
don't it seems like an innovative time
in opportune time to do that but yeah it
is a great console i mean you can stand
vertically now if you're into that
yeah okay uh
it's what it's doing um yeah i don't
know i i
find it a much more
i find it a much more attractive console
and i find it much
uh easier to use uh jake decker my
roommate and uh co-worker has an xbox
one like a launch day xbox one and he's
probably listening right now and
uh like hating himself but they still
need to work on this os this os is a
mess
they have improved it slightly but
that's not saying that because it's
still slow it's still it's i thought so
i thought you were right and then i
realized i think you're wrong like
like change of heart it is just it looks
cooler and you think it's it's there but
for some reason it is so difficult it's
like four steps to get to your library
of games
or redeem a code yeah no idea so many
things go to mordor toss the ring in the
fire come back i don't [ __ ] yeah i
mean whatever
uh yeah it's tough
but i would say like another cool thing
is it was nice to see a lot of i mean
probably because they had to right but a
lot of awesome bundles like yeah they
were going for
pretty damn good prices right like uh
battlefield one like endless i don't
know what packages they were called but
there's so many of them there sometimes
it was like here here's three games with
your console yeah uh yeah i mean it's if
you're looking to buy one of those like
there was a there was a window of like
these things just like hotcakes you know
what do you guys think of the xbox play
anywhere program which is just cross
play between windows 10 and xbox one
it's messy have you tried it apparently
cross saves don't work on dead rising
four really yeah the most
a game that released today mm-hmm damn
that's what i've heard anyway i remember
with uh i think it was gears of war
ultimate edition they were really
pushing it and i tried it out the first
time
that was i believe so that was last year
and uh
it always just felt like they were just
trying to push windows 10 us because
like they're doing that and then of
course you get that
window that pops up all the time that
annoys you in that way so they're kind
of it's like a two-tiered approach
of being negative yeah um no but the two
other the two ones i tried that actually
were pretty damn good was forza uh
was seamless like i was going back and
forth between xbox one and pc like
office and home like like no big deal at
all i had a good experience with gears
four okay it didn't have any big hiccups
at all i think any hiccups i had was
just
updating windows 10 or something and
forge was it was a kind of a unique one
too right oh halo 5 right and then uh
yeah custom games which is they're
releasing their next update for halo
uh
it's just like this game's on pc now you
know like if they're doing you're able
to find custom uh
matches which are like that's that's
huge i mean that's that's multiplayer it
seems weird to bring that up because
it's so niche right halo forge but it
does feel like that's where it's
supposed to be on pc the ease that you
can just like click and drag things move
around the map uh creating these maps
people are creating like star wars endor
maps people were creating these intro
cut scenes with darth vader burning on
the pyre uh people were just creating
crazy things like giant like
full scale foosball tables that you're
walking around and playing on um but it
does feel like that's where that kind of
you know found its home but i do want to
talk about backwards compatibility i
think this year was the year that it
just like
exploded and microsoft you know was
promising hundreds more on the way or
like what does that really mean but they
really have it's been like
at least three a week it seems like and
then i think uh i read a news story that
we published in october and it was twice
a week i think that's happened a lot
actually it'll we'll just be like oh
they just released you know red dead
redemption or mass effect 3 gears of war
the entire trilogy which that came out
with like uh ultimate edition and
whatnot but yeah they've been making
good on this promise i think the
library's at least 300 right now reading
through it earlier i was gonna like i
went in thinking maybe we could touch on
most of them i was like no we would it
would take hours to get into them you
know like uh just last week we put they
put uh
what they get into i mean like elder
scrolls four oblivion was recent
injustice gods among us dead space fable
two fallout three again the year's war
trilogy left for dead one and two portal
two rayman origin spelunky the witcher
two
if you're if you have any games you
wanna play on 360.
again like black ops 2 i think is the
one people been asking about the most
and they haven't done it yet but odds
are if you want to play a 360 game on
xbox one it's a pretty good chance
you'll have it it's physical and digital
too um and unlike sony who
oh my god they could easily have ps1
games playable if you stick a disc in
the system that's not a thing
you can play ps2 games but you have to
buy them again like with xbox one the
games that you already own work that you
don't have to do anything so microsoft
is going out of their way to do
something that's good for the fans and
then making it as easy as as possible
for them to realize that once it's
finally available which is just amazing
it's incredible like that's
they deserve the i think the most credit
for that this year yeah i mean it was
kind of a big event i remember when the
mass effect when mass effect 3 came to
xbox one i think we did a live stream or
something it's always like oh [ __ ] this
is up it's like you almost forget that
they're constantly pouring these into
the xbox one but then when like one of
your favorite 360 or xbox games or even
like old school like symphony and knight
came to xbox one i've been playing that
360 for like four years and i was like
holy [ __ ] i should just go play that
because i have my xbox one hooked up i
want to play that game i might as well
play that in that format it's just a new
excuse to do so and it feels like uh
microsoft has really been making good on
the promise to keep that library you
know just like fueled it's a pretty damn
cool feeling to like i i just now turned
on the xbox one and actually went
through like all of my digital purchases
and you just scroll through like oh [ __ ]
i i have that game and that was the year
decade ago right or more it's like wow
it's there because that's a big concern
right like yeah there have been many
times where i've bought in a movie
even like on itunes and like lost my
account or something like that you know
i mean like it's
you think you're doing digital purchases
and it's it's safe but not always and
this is like clear cut like example of
like this is you know yeah again a
decade later and it's like there they
are i'm still buying like digital stuff
that sony puts on sale for like ps3 and
then i realized crap now i gotta hook up
my ps3 to play this right yeah right
whereas like xbox you scroll into your
library like kingdom for keflings what
the hell are you doing here and then you
just i didn't i don't play it it's a
game i haven't thought about dude and
saves or transferring too like mass
effect one i was playing uh i'd played
two three and then like i was like i
gotta try one because i love that series
so much and uh sorry about a while ago
i'm sorry mass effect oh okay
uh yeah you know
i think that was one of the first games
they actually had backwards compatible
and there's my save from the xbox 360
like yeah the power of the cloud i mean
red dead redemption releasing on that
was big with the red dead redemption 2
release about sorry wow announcement
i wish that released about a month or
two ago we did that live stream and
everything played red dead redemption on
xbox one went great felt fine different
controller and console but same
experience it's nice yeah it's nice to
like
not you know if you wanted to like
rekindle that fire when the game
eventually comes out you know you have
to buy it again right like it's there
with your save yeah so uh backwards
compatibility definitely one of the high
points of xbox one this year and
judged on the last few months we can see
a lot more of those releasing i do want
to touch on the software though there
are a few exclusives and everything
obviously there are a few shared titles
between uh the platforms but uh pete you
reviewed quantum break
uh
thought it was all right i think it was
pretty divisive right like a few outlets
really liked it oh yeah which was
surprising uh because i played it i
didn't really love it i don't think i
think it was pretty unremarkable
especially you see games like
uh you know like i don't want to spoil
this now you see other games doing like
time control pretty pretty well and
quantum break didn't seem to do anything
it seemed like more spectacle and
everything there's a lot of spectacle
and it led to some interesting stuff um
but the uh i think what everyone really
took away from that game was like hey
this thing uses tv episodes it mixes it
with
gameplay and
you can kind of tell that like the the
share of like the resources that went
into this thing like weren't even and
some points were probably like missing
like
cars repeating shot from shot during a
car chase scene in the tv oh yeah
just low budget type stuff just low but
low budget stuff that made you like not
really care about the show and then some
like kind of poor acting and writing as
well uh but then yeah the game play was
super boring because you'd be in combat
and have these great abilities and that
was pretty good there were some problems
in there but then you'd be outside like
rewinding time to like move a
two by four so you could cross over a
dumpster like oh god talk about
deflating like
yeah yeah not the best exclusive to hang
your hat on yeah your reviews up on the
site people go read more in depth on
that if they want to uh here's what four
i reviewed that was a good game i really
like horde mode i think uh you know it's
the developer the coalition with uh rod
ferguson who initially was founded black
tusk but then of course became the
coalition when they got the gears of war
franchise a lot of gears of war
veterans were working on it i think this
game was uh great in a lot of ways they
perfected horde i think uh
the campaign was fun but i don't think i
think it's pretty unremarkable uh and
then you know multiplayer they added a
few new modes and made you know gears of
war multiplayer even better than it
already was i don't think they changed
too much i know a lot of people love
this game and i don't blame them it's uh
there's a lot to like
uh forza horizon 3 we've all played at
least a little bit right uh took this
open world racing and kind of just
made this huge australian wilderness
that you could drive through uh you know
doing side quests and whatnot uh what'd
you guys think of this game rob you
played it a little bit right i played it
more than i thought i would i'm not like
a huge uh
racing fan but
uh
it's hard for me to compare it to its
predecessor
yet
there was just something about what kept
me going in this open world was that it
was a really awesome open world and
the diversity and tasks and
moment-to-moment
uh
features were just so plentiful that i
just found myself glued to it you know
you
just you had such freedom you know you
could
you know fly through a vineyard or look
for a new car you you could find you
know just race people randomly on on the
road there was something about like
just consistently driving and it
it just it you know it's realistic but
it's also a lot of fun and that's where
they they didn't hold anything back and
it it kind of like to me makes me feel
like
it makes me wish you know we all wish we
could go 120 on 280 you know like we
can't but jesus take the wheel right
right just like no hands do it right uh
there's something about that it kind of
like it tickles that like
that fantasy of just like
going
fast mm-hmm
yeah definitely such a smooth experience
and just pleasant to exist in and just
yeah just be there like having played a
lot of the crew which kind of tackles a
similar sort of like gameplay
um promise it's just the moment to
moment in forza horizon just feels so
much better in almost every regard yeah
we've been talking obviously this week
we've been looking back at all the
releases this year and every time we
talk about forza it's kind of the racing
game that made racing game fans out of
people who might not otherwise be and i
think forza does that uh consistently
but definitely forza horizon 3 uh
especially this year the and well the
online components are really awesome too
i i was definitely like into the free
roam and seeing like just packs of guys
just like tearing up on the runway out
of the desert or the outback excuse me
um seeing you know one of my friends
who's playing like
got a new time trial on this on this
race do you want it like it'll just say
like do you want to try topham yeah and
i'm like damn right like that's just and
that's just actually in the single
player now i think about it like it's
just a nice
mixture uh between the two like sure
it's fun yeah it's a really fun game to
touch on one more exclusive before we uh
close the segment out uh recore kg under
the supervision of keiji inafune of mega
man and mighty number nine fame
or in fame uh
didn't really deliver it seemed
promising in a few
respects before release you know it
seemed like a
this blend of kind of a metroid prime
game with which i had portrait prime
developers on it from what i understand
as well um and then you know like kind
of mega man 3d mega man combat
uh from what i played it just didn't
really connect i don't think it came to
fruition uh timur hussein the uk i
believe reviewed it and i think he felt
you know similar he didn't feel like he
felt unpolished in a lot of areas kind
of you know
a little superficial in others but uh i
mean it's an interesting game it's it's
it's worth maybe checking out for a
couple hours seeing what it is if you
had like a like a
big fondness for the sort of stuff we
saw when the playstation 2 was around
this game kind of embodies a lot of uh
what those games did which was very
familiar kind of accessible action
shooting gameplay in this regard um with
some polish with some spectacle added on
to it and i don't think anyone's gonna
argue that this game doesn't have that
it's just like very pure simple fun
action stuff
uh
the thing that tomorrow a lot of other
people hung up on was that you have to
collect these orbs like throughout the
world to beat the game yeah and it is
like you pass by these environments and
you could have got them in the first
place but the game doesn't really give
you any hint as to how to find them and
so at the end of the game you gotta go
find them all sorry sure like it's just
a
it just doesn't seem like they were able
to take it to you know
it didn't go full stop right it just
kind of like got somewhere and was like
well we just need to push this out we
told people would be out they're excited
for it we don't want to make them worry
sure kind of a disappointment at least
for me and like like you said for you
and a lot of other people into more and
everything and uh it just doesn't i
don't know didn't really deliver uh but
you can play it you can check it out if
you want and uh yeah xbox one uh you
know like x with the scorpio i almost
said it again xbox one scorpio with
scorpio on the horizon we uh you know
like just like the nintendo switch a lot
of promise for the console uh for
updating it and whatnot for microsoft in
general but uh if you want to read the
reviews for any of those exclusives go
check them out on gamespot and uh yeah
the report card for xbox one is actually
up whether you're watching this live or
as a breakout so you can go read that by
chris pereira our news one of our news
editors uh go check that out
rob thanks for joining us oh i know i'm
out
with the exit
uh rob handler bringing on jake decker
to talk ps4 this is our last segment for
the day
you guys almost 3 30. yeah it's almost 3
30. we're actually kind of on schedule
surprisingly i thought like rob would
talk too much or justin would like
destroy something that we have to fix
during the shoot but uh
yeah he was very on time he was early
today it was crazy you've got trouble
when you're complaining about it i give
him i give him [ __ ] all the time but
yeah all right let's dig into the ps4
end of the year uh closed out that
you're pretty strong with exclusives
again two games that we didn't
know when we would finally see nope
until we saw him and then we reviewed
him if we're peter brown both of them
nope
what one final fantasy is not exclusive
sorry [ __ ] one big exclusive but another
game we didn't see but been playing fun
office down ps4 yeah i was like why are
you saying nope over and over what am i
saying wrong
he was reveling in as you kept talking
secretly it's been a long episode yes uh
but yes ps4
two new iterations of the ps4 have
released this year um again we saw a few
exclusives we kind of you know
saw the beginning of this like this
these consoles being updated much like
you might have pc almost maybe not as
often or as in depth but ps4 slim
released p let's talk about that quick
what
did that change was just the size was it
like what like of the hardware would
make this appealing to someone who
didn't initially have a ps4 cheaper
smaller um
i think just more pleasing in terms of
uh both his aesthetic and the materials
that it uses um
and it came with hdr support which now
is
uh supported by the entire playstation
line but uh
yeah it's just like a more refined
system i think there was like the
original design was sort of like
look at this like very like you know
slick design thing and now it's just
like all right it's just a good game
console we've made it a little bit
smoother so
that's it i like the original design
more yeah yeah i think so like the
sharp edges parallelogram kind of thing
yeah um all right i forget if it's a
parallelogram or a rhombus one of those
is the other i'm not a geometrist uh ps4
pro a few months later hit me with that
why would i want to get this more power
um
that's it yeah hdr hdr is is you know
that's you can get that on any of the
playstations uh 4k is a thing but it's
you know uh it's not perfect there's a
lot of issues some don't some do some
yeah it's like the sort of fears i had
when microsoft was talking about the
scorpio d3 was like true 4k gaming it's
like stop lying to people like yeah it's
you're not going to get 60 frames per
second 4k at the same fidelity you had
at 1080p
and you know yes the scorpio may be more
powerful than the pro but here we are
with a system that is upgraded that is
offering a very similar promise and it's
kind of doing it but not really
um
it comes with a bigger hard drive on the
pro that's nice doesn't have the blue
rays doesn't have blu-ray it has blu-ray
doesn't have uhd doesn't have uhd
support yeah which
scorpio does does we don't know
the s does that does s does the scorpion
doesn't make stuff yeah they need to
come up with a new name because scorpio
and s
are similar what were you just going to
say jake uh i mean i think with the ps4
pro at least it seems more it seems like
something if you don't have a ps4 it
would be
good to get i guess and if you have a 4k
hdr tv or if you don't like i don't know
it's cool that you have that option but
i don't think i'd
get it at least not right now no
and it's
like a lot of people were hoping and i'm
glad it didn't turn out this way because
i it i don't sound like a liar after the
fact but it does not benefit playstation
vr you still have to use that breakout
box everyone say oh you're gonna have to
do it with the pro it's gonna be this vr
machine and that's not the case yeah
psvr you just brought it up i know it's
segue thank you i'm getting tired you're
not i'm very tired oh man all right so
psvr like we talked about this
extensively earlier on the show uh this
is the first year we have an actual vr
category in our end of the year awards
uh psvr is most accessible by price and
i think again if you're not if you
weren't really on the lookout for vr and
you see that it's there for your console
that you've owned for four years
go for it i guess we'll like just go for
it just get it get after it the in terms
of the software library uh we mentioned
this a little bit hit or miss kind of
jimmy said he thinks a few titles are
like worth the purchase punching above
their weight yeah i mean uh don't really
worry about them being exclusive or not
right i think yeah just the fact that
it's great on a console alone is special
uh would be thumper it's an amazing vr
game and that works wonders on ps4 uh
rez is a ps4 exclusive res infinite and
that is special as well
a few misses you know along the way like
rush of blood
the uh what was the series that was tied
to until dawn right but that was like on
rails weird stand-alone spin-off going
through an amusement park firing light
guns i mean the software needs to catch
up and we don't really have a great
sense of uh what the next great vr title
will be for playstation 4 but it's
certainly like
it's easy to set up it works well and
it's comfortable to use it's just a
matter of time for developers to say
okay cool people like this let's give
them what they want as a fan of resident
evil i'm hoping resume will make good
use but i've played it i'm not totally
convinced yet but you know maybe when
i'm playing through an entire
playthrough i'll change my mind uh it
also is a sorry what i was going to say
i hope that
even if i don't love vr in resident evil
7 for the whole time you know it uses
those tapes to like put you in new
scenarios i can imagine just like
distinct like one-off moments in that
game where you're like i want this
moment in vr yeah to feel like you have
to do the whole yeah we mentioned this
earlier you could just you go one
playthrough you could load up a save
right vr whenever you don't have to
dedicate your commit to one vr play
through one just standard playthrough so
that would be like ease of use in
general and you know jimmy was saying
this is probably the most comfortable
headset it is yeah by far because you've
solved them pretty extensively yeah no
it's it's so simple to use and it's
balanced really well it's heavier than i
think the vive but you wouldn't know it
so i think psvr accomplished what it
needed to as far as like bringing vr to
that audience and i think you know like
showing promise definitely and like i
said here's hoping it you know follows
through with resident evil 7. um skin of
the games before we uh close out the
show the last guardian most recent we
talked we didn't ask the reviewer with
you earlier in the show uh you know if
you want to watch that you can go dive
into that on your own but i do want to
touch on it yeah great game you gave out
a 9 out of 10 despite some frustrations
this nailed it after what 10 years in
development yeah it is it is just an
amazing game that you you can't point to
anything parallel on any other platform
i mean it's
it's not that it could only be done on
playstation 4 but that's the only place
you can play it and you really i think
everyone should experience the last
guardian i'm going to bounce back and
forth between like bigger games and some
like not like such huge triple-a games
jake you brought up alienation today
from a house mark house marquee house
marquette
house mark i was right the first time
stop me when i'm doing this
house mark jake you and i have played
this cooperatively a lot uh i kind of
like had the same kind of like it's like
diablo mixed with hell divers if you
played those two uh i don't know what
you like this game a lot didn't you yeah
i had a lot of fun with it i we didn't
play as much as i would have liked but
you and i together played quite a bit
and i think it's just
it it does have a lot of those kind of
complexities that diablo does like the
loot grinding but it still has that
great sort of feel to it that how smart
games typically have at least you know
most people think of resogun
um in it
it plays great it feels great it's a lot
of fun especially if you've got co-op
um i know at first at launch though and
i don't think there was couch co-op but
now there is um it's definitely worth
looking into i think uh this isn't a
console exclusive anymore uh the witness
originally released for ps4 and uh
windows i believe in january and then
september it's since come to xbox one
but originally it was a ps4 exclusive i
reviewed this gave it a nine out of ten
this is one of my favorite games of the
year uh i think this game is really
important it's tough to show it in
gameplay like we're showing now i'm sure
you've heard of it by now it's uh i
think it was really famous because
jonathan blow who did braid uh worked on
it and you know like
you can call braid and this game
pretentious and i think they very much
are to a certain extent but this game is
really special i think they take these
mazes and they take the world and tie
them together and tell this really cool
contextual environmental story
in such a way that it is one of my most
memorable experiences one of the hardest
games i've ever played one of the most
like intellectually challenging and uh
just tested my patience in so many ways
throughout the process but it's well
worth checking out and i think the ps4
was uh better off the beginning this
year for it you're like a psychopath and
you're reviewing yeah like a notebook
that you'd open up like write things
down you're like i couldn't even be
playing the game like what's he doing
over there like sketching out like
you're different yeah
yeah
michael hayam our associate tech editor
was uh
i he had a notebook open on his desk
today are you playing the witness he's
like yeah i'm finally getting into it
like dude i think everybody has that
like psychopath like serial killer
notebook somewhere made of human skin
yes made of hair and what's weird is
that after a while you're just writing
down people you're gonna kill yeah it
wasn't even slowly it was just all mic
you just start looking more and more
like jonathan blow the more you play it
okay uh so yeah the beginning this year
ps4 kicked it off really well with that
uh
big game followed in march maybe may i
reviewed this game i shouldn't know when
it released on chart four probably the
bigger exclusive aside for me the last
guardian for ps4 this year
naughty dog it was the first uncharted
without amy hennig writing uh of you
know like she does she's doing like
working on star wars titles now
up at uh ea and everything and uh i
really love this game i gave it a 10 out
of 10.
um you could throw food at me if you
want or something uh tomatoes if we were
in a crowded theater hall uh no i i love
this game i think
they not only did it tell an amazing uh
character-driven nuanced story on its
own in a world that with moments i have
not forgotten yet and i don't think i
ever will it actually addressed nathan
drake as a character from the first
three games it made the first three
games
even more powerful i don't love the
first game i think the two is fantastic
game like i think the general consensus
says three i think stumbled a little bit
but i still love it four
i think it's the best uncharted game it
is one of my favorite games
ever i i love this game i love the uh
the set pieces in it like just being
dragged through the mud on these trucks
jumping from truck to truck and
motorcycle motorcycle in madagascar this
these it's gorgeous i can't say enough
about it i want to talk about it more
but unfortunately we don't have time but
jake i know you liked uncharted yeah
pete you both liked uncharted 4 a lot
yeah i think like
at least my favorite thing with
uncharted 4 is that like uncharted 1 2
and 3 those stories felt very much about
nathan drake and this one does too
but it does put a lot of focus on a lot
of its side characters something that
you're actually bringing up yesterday
like um
elena plays a huge role in this like
just
those two interacting and there's like a
great scene that i know we've talked
about a lot of them yeah yeah or there's
one there's one in particular that i
think you know what i'm talking about um
and then sully too and it's just
it's just a beautiful ending to
a series that i've grown so attached to
i don't think it's just like a great
like indiana jones-esque story anymore i
think they actually explored how his
actions and his adventures have affected
the people around him and i think it was
pretty powerful and i think if you
finish the game you know it kind of
becomes about why these stories can be
important and like how they can help
people and i thought it was an amazing
game in
every single way um and then no man's
sky released on you know ps4 back in
june
yes we've been waiting for that for a
while and again another game with a long
development cycle pete naturally you
would review it as you did the rest of
this year uh you liked this game you
gave a seven out of ten from what i
remember and uh since been updated with
a big patch that has these freighters
and base building which rob said makes
the game better but doesn't like
drastically change it but uh yeah i
think a lot of people there's a lot of
[ __ ] surrounding this game now because
you know whether it be like developer
promises like perceived developer
promises whether they delivered on that
or not i don't know but in general you
you seem to like this game i mean they
basically promised a slicker more
accessible eve online and and what we
got was not that yeah um you can't meet
other people in the world even if you
are on the same planet you will not see
them
uh you will run into stuff that people
named but that's about it
and so what what you're left with is
just a massive galaxy
uh where you're hopping between star
systems and it all happens very
seamlessly with kind of trippy spectacle
that just adds a bit of magic to the
whole process and then you dive down
into these planets and explore
you know some are very pleasant some are
very hazardous
some have no resources at all and you've
doomed yourself by landing and walking
away from your ship others are just rich
and bountiful and you're leaving behind
like it's that old story of like you
know someone trying to carry too much
treasure out of a you know a place in
like dooming themselves because they
were so greedy i mean this game you can
kill yourself by being too greedy
because you're spending too much time
and just dying um
very fascinating game for a lot of
reasons but it's missing that the heart
and soul like the only motivation in the
game other two is
one to get to the center of the galaxy
um and two is to follow this path uh
this thing called atlas is sort of
beckoning you i found that to be really
fulfilling it was kind of short-lived
and it was very
linear in how it was told so while very
interesting it wasn't enough to elevate
the game to
like a must-play game
really happy i played it i think i put
like 70 hours into it and i i could have
played a little bit more definitely um
if not for new games yeah and obviously
again it's been updated since uh very
recently about a week ago and uh you can
play it in that updated form now
so yeah overall pretty strong lineup for
ps4 this year there was no bloodborne so
that's a bummer
there's no bloodborne two yet let's hope
that getting announced
my game of the year is there older
hunters no old hunters
end of last year but still anyway so
yeah uh again if you're watching this
live it's not up yet but if you're
watching this on youtube or gamespot you
can read the more in-depth end of the
year report card for ps4 written by one
of our editors and uh go check that out
wow there's a long episode it's 3 40.
dang not too far off i was i was trying
to be between 3 30 3 40 so we're right
on the cusp anyway jake and pete
jake thanks for coming for this segment
pete thanks for being for the whole show
everybody watching thank you so much for
uh
joining us for this longer episode
jean-luc steipky mary kish and eric tay
in the back thanks for helping us out
back there with the tricaster and
whatnot and uh we have another the
second segment of our game of the year
deliberations to go into right now um
yeah seriously throughout this week next
week the week after that all throughout
the holidays and whatnot we will have
end of the year game of the year stuff
to talk about we'll have report cards
we'll have more
in-depth discussions about our top 25
games our top five games
and uh yeah as always
thanks so much for joining us we'll see
you next time
[Music]
you